[Inaudible] altered carbon
[inaudible].
Altered carbon.
Or some shared hot [inaudible].
[Inaudible] bit of that mood or so her
[inaudible] or, um, [inaudible] mean partner
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] uh, the odd, uh,
[inaudible] text today unlocked a and
E.
I'll be a potential Turner [inaudible] um,
[inaudible] uh
[inaudible] okay.
[Inaudible] Diane
[inaudible].
It is special to me. In fact, this thread, um,
y'all have the N y'all have the teal stone, the,
some had the pectus excavatum so you'll have [inaudible] group
immune breast, Cory
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] you'll have the equivalent
[inaudible] so the only here, let me leave so high all the, um, uh,
cramps or truly for up top material. So
[inaudible], uh,
[inaudible] the flat, the breast Corian
[inaudible] so the [inaudible] pump snapped.
So, uh, so Tori moved flattened
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] and Yan balk a little bit platinum, platinum bulks,
a heart for
[inaudible] [inaudible] to her was as a vendor important. We'll get it.
But as Korean
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Oh, those are the three or,
or they have a fake that how your bet proceeds after the audio to opera
Hunan. So Tovar is a new year.
[Inaudible].
Yeah. Hi [inaudible] yeah.
Okay.
Um, the true absolutes, um, sensitive,
used to have real quick that alter carbon, they were
[inaudible] the role TDRs committee in of
[inaudible] tank [inaudible], um,
[inaudible], um, evicted from Mayo score, but, um,
atmospheric
[inaudible] for the [inaudible] in, uh,
for Inteva [inaudible], but EMR Eminem,
who will also come back and set the tune of, um, your, your, your
[inaudible] best on their Naria and Snell or caught our better understanding.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible], [inaudible] be a swatch cross-team [inaudible].
So the [inaudible] the full cows. That's the
[inaudible] for may. OPEX is
[inaudible] school on Australia. They had a year in this vehicle report.
[inaudible] the alarm, her, um, some car going and
[inaudible], uh, OEM at them. [inaudible]
um, when you're holding the [inaudible],
it's not a socket till may of
[inaudible] feminists. So bill we'll call
[inaudible] on things to me is so extreme. [inaudible].
So do you understand [inaudible] mood? I'm doing, uh,
I'm doing political. You mean
some calorie called feminist meet ex [inaudible] was Harvey
Weinstein. Oh yeah. We had a
[inaudible] [inaudible] semester on mainly the [inaudible] bitmap that
[inaudible] hotel room. Okay.
We'll get to him. Um, so the
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Nate.
Naming it. So
y'all been fam six. [inaudible] had the
[inaudible] Kevin [inaudible] Hollywood. Um,
I mean our project, uh, um, I got meth Valley farm, welcome number Baltimore.
Um, man, that must sound them. I figured out that pull up, uh, hung up the, um,
[inaudible], uh, uh, some fuel to know learning our [inaudible]
tackle. Hey man.
[Inaudible].
Yeah, I'm going to be stopped [inaudible] Mr.
[inaudible]. Um.
[Inaudible] up the fence a long way. [inaudible].
Oh, absolutely. The source for.
[Inaudible]. Yeah.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] um, or so
step one then blindfold. I can't
[inaudible] [inaudible] Gordon. Um,
[inaudible] sat there and they meet some man heading and abuse to gov
and it's a blindfold. Um, also
[inaudible] thousands Sotheby and yet, uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh, [inaudible] lesson at the same day,
marriage.com
[inaudible] Boulevard. Uh
[inaudible] [inaudible] um, what's the
[inaudible] in this school is that you want to get married? I say, yes.
Okay. $435 and it quick, quickly, so, okay.
So you've been on so far and on my little stool sound,
so come, uh, dinner could be none. It, um,
we'll also get some notes, like, Oh,
well I'm almost like
[inaudible] or Southern [inaudible] Claire.
This [inaudible] some
[inaudible].
Sure.
[Inaudible] some, uh, I also want to say you wanted to get married.
Uh, correct. Uh,
because standing inside chapel, um, excuse me, bus stand inside.
Chapel Casey green
[inaudible] uh, uh,
saw a marriage arrest of your life.
Say yes.
Yes. [inaudible]. So.
The rest of your life say yes.
Yes. Merit.
[Inaudible].
Yeah.
So we sort of set the bar log leads. Um,
man, uh
[inaudible] as a liberal loves Fest.
[Inaudible] hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.